another stars always looked amazing
mister Aashiqui Hansen oh yes yes yes
in her new movie what men want taraji
plays a sports agent who just so happens
to represent a player on the Atlanta
Hawks so over the weekend taraji invited
in the shell Turner to join her
courtside at a Hawks game for this et
exclusive has it sunk into you yet
really that you're the lead of a
romantic comedy yeah I did taraji is
having a moment not only is she starring
in a new rom-com she's engaged to the
love of her life former NFL pro Kelvin
Hayden and the Empire star is an
outspoken advocate for women in the
industry but she admits she couldn't do
it without her weekly therapy session
how does that help you work on you my
job is to be fake I'm not in a bad way
but I get paid to tell lies so I have to
make the keep a balance with all of the
Hollywood and being a single mom yeah so
it's just best to go to a professional
to help you balance all of it out what
men want flips the script on the mm Mel
Gibson film what women want
taraji gains a career edge when she
develops the ability to hear men's
thoughts starting today no more drinking
at work hey that's too much information
or anything so I want to play a little
game called say what now I want you to
look at pictures of your past male
co-stars okay and tell me what you think
they're thinking in these photos
Shaquille yeah what do you think he's
thinking in this book I'm hot I want to
take this suit off I'm about to sweat
that's what she look like you're saying
Shaq
Kevin Hart I'm a comedic rock star look
at me and shine I don't know I'm a
little man
my wife romantic what they want hits
theaters February 8th
[Music]